[Music]
two months after the Japanese bombed
Pearl Harbor in 1941 President Franklin
Roosevelt authorized the removal of
persons considered a threat when he was
five years old
less Okita was one of them he was sent
to internment camps with his family I
think about the people like my parents
they suffered a lot more and my father I
think about the dreams he had for a very
lucrative successful career was very
much shattered by the internment he
drank too much he died at the early age
of 59 when she was interned Christina
Maeda came down with pneumonia and was
separated from her family and that was
totally darkened in all 120,000 Japanese
Americans were put into internment camps
survivors came to California's Capitol
in Sacramento this week to hear
legislators denounce what they always
knew was wrong we will not stand for
racist and paranoid policies that take
away basic rights from any person in a
unanimous decision state lawmakers voted
to apologize for the federal
government's internment program it's a
nice thing that our country they can
still have the integrity
and be able to apologize even if it took
that long the 10 internment camps closed
in 1945 the people in them were allowed
to go home and once again call America
home I think about the good and the bad
about the internment experience here our
country has put us behind barbed wire
and then we still remain good citizens
pleasures of allegiance to our flag it
still is unbelievable 100,000 yeah a
hundred and twenty seven thousand and by
the way the apology from California
comes 32 years after the US government
paid reparations to 82,000 survivors
it's still just this dark chapter that
we have to know about you have to talk
about but it seems unbelievable that it
happened yeah reparations interesting